put so much into it let you know I mean
in small mistakes like that Hannam just
a little bit right and these guys of
course now guaranteed top 5 of course a
huge shout out to ASCO for supporting
the Tekken World Tour you know of course
they added so much money to the prize
pool and it's at the present now of
course the prize will up to $250,000
unbelievable stuff these guys here
guaranteed a minimum of fifth place
that's 12,500 just from there if they
win this match and they guarantee
themself a top 4 finish that's a minimum
of $25,000 so here's this patch $1,500
that's actually tear down our house I
don't even live there all right guys
here we go I got a question
I have a quest what the questions if you
guys would like you I use double to take
the scent and stay alive make some noise
out there
I like the one dude the jacket right
there what stood up okay he's really all
about double what about fate old son if
you would like him to take it make some
noise ladies and gentlemen oh wow okay
they're louder but nobody stood up I'm
gonna go with that one that's the one
representative galloping I gotta let him
know double look at him he's like thanks
for the support man I mean I stood up to
let's be honest Devil's pit
The Devil's pit here we go man Japan has
been super loud it's been ridiculous
awesome at Japan's career vishudhi has
been running up around everywhere at
this place I love fitness energy here we
go law vs. kazoo mm-hmm Ulsan versus
double top five action bull breaker Lex
he's so good flash punch combo he gets
so much off of that knock down a lot of
his games have come back just like
hitting that flash punch combo on the
guests that come from doesn't matter
double get the first round he looks so
much more comfortable in this match
fight and even more so just the fact
that I feel like ol son of the week back
- everything at his range is just
waiting for something specific I feel
like the last set right before the whip
punish one loss best tools pressure on
the wall hit commit to it not after what
happened last time yeah that's
definitely true now for one once again
lots of sony back and board right now
double advantage on this side when it
comes to the light beautiful again get
the whip whip punches ready and boom the
legend kick double is looking sharp
right now and you said yourself like
fight double has just started using that
and look at what it dumped on two rounds
super quick
all right infinite stage now see we're
all sorry once again man we've been
saying a lot of people not just back -
cancel but just walk back out of these
strings to get clean punished right
there that's wall 10-4 and there's a DSS
cancel after it and so a few times that
also has already back tested ensues that
wall standing for is blocked oh nice
that should be the rounded play properly
uh-huh and I was just slightly missed
time by W went for the parry on that
kick because just barely missed it okay
Oh sign gave me one on the fort
crowd let them know they're still with
back one lets it rip running to go oh
okay we're taking these these small
little Pope's to get him back to where
he needs to get that leave in this match
he is on match point right now flash
punch sometimes you got to use those
little Pope's just to see what your
opponent does on reaction step like do
they decide to do they back then do they
hit a button deuce is just - in your
face - do nothing Oh Oh God you went
back to it again
not this time close down final round
game one just man these guys are going
for tit for tat right now yeah back in
port double back it up a little bit love
to you since you're the one - quick
sidewalk Wow while standing foo-foo on
top of it trade no magic conversion
victory of the back want to track that
time
oh what a dog and a punish whoa mm-hmm
[Music]
saunas turn things around completely
right now get hit face it's my favorite
soup Sunday's best this is final okay
hey nappa double back three twenty
seconds left on the clock
previously in the one to two excellent
damage on that one and what a comeback
from wool sock and he's been ducking at
the perfect time and he's actually been
punishing it and look what it did it
gave him that match yeah and those first
two rounds was so clearly in favor of
double but old son not sure what the
adaptation was but clearly figured out
something in that first game we were
talking about his movement and how it's
been helping him out I feel like it does
a great job of making him control the
pace right you're gonna second-guess
swinging if he's going in and out like
that playing that range game so
effectively on top of just capitalizing
you see him ducking in between no
strings still getting the punish closing
out rounds just the same and like you
said double was in control it's seep
seemingly in control but most of that
match yeah I think you don't know
success he had was with the wood punches
on that 3+4 that step and kick from
lawful at the same time I feel like will
sign adapt as I said like I'm not gonna
give you big enough with such a people
cannot punt it with that cool looking in
try to go for the throat nice jab
doubles definitely awake and all son is
so prepared but it is a bad idea
counter it down back three this time do
it again right after while standing for
beats basically every DSS optical sights
a bright duck
you'll beat every single DSS object
that's why only something good put the
magic wore off point waltz up in them
all day long and now he kept the first
round here in Game two and it's crazy
how often he actually hits the the magic
for County here right like sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't but I feel
like whenever he uses the four it's
always the counter
I'll splat Wow what a conversion off of
that I'm in shock that was amazing
factory once again look at these Pope's
adding up ulsan and rage
oh I'll block the reaction from double
paying off I'm trying to find a way in
once again the downfall you want to all
silos to let that rip yeah cuz otherwise
you have to challenge or it you can you
can learn to download one all day so so
eventually you got to take your turn
when you do it's just gonna finish this
ring jockey for position right now
slowly getting pushed to that wall all
sign is oh poor lost any pointed SF
holds on is so prepared for it and don't
keep donut antenna like that set point
fatal side this do Olson is ridiculous
double in danger of going home needs to
make something happen right now this is
definitely losses side two out of three
is the name of the game set point see
the Ken there he's still doing it and it
really good to control this round is not
helping the throw in every time it just
makes them leave with something Crouch
three can connect four again
all the way to the walls going be coming
into one more chance here and the log
kick Oh eliminates you I use double he's
gonna move on further on that losers
side guys make some noise for you what
you double ganger best players in the
world definitely one of the best players
in the world
yeah